There's another important technique for
regularization
that only emerged relatively
recently and works amazingly well.
It also looks insane the first
time you see it, so bear with me.
It's called dropout.
Dropout works likes this.
Imagine that you have one layer
that connects to another layer.
The values that go from one layer to
the next are often called activations.
Now take those activations and
randomly for
every example you train your network on,
set half of them to zero.
Completely randomly, you basically take
half of the data that's flowing through
your network and just destroy it.
And then randomly again.
If that doesn't sound crazy to you then
you might qualify to become a student of
Jeffery Hinton who
pioneered the technique.
So what happens with dropout?
Your network can never rely on any
given activation to be present
because they might be
squashed at any given moment.
So it is forced to learn
a redundant representation for
everything to make sure that at least
some of the information remains.
It's like a game of whack-a-mole.
One activations gets smashed,
but there's always one or
more that do the same job and
that don't get killed.
So everything remains fine at the end.
Forcing your network to learn redundant
representations might sound very
inefficient.
But in practice, it makes things more
robust and prevents over fitting.
It also makes your network act
as if taking the consensus
over an ensemble of networks.
Which is always a good way
to improve performance.
Dropout is one of the most important
techniques to emerge in the last few
years.
If drop out doesn't work for
you, you should probably
be using a bigger network.